so i'm going to give a another quick
overview of photosynthesis and this time
i'm going to break it down into
two big stages so as you are probably
familiar just looking at the word
photosynthesis essentially has two parts
has photo and it has synthesis
the photo is referring to that it's
going to use light somehow and what's it
going to do with that light energy well
it's going to synthesize something and
what in particular what it's going to
synthesize as we'll see is sugar so we
are going to go from
energy in light let me just write light
light energy and we're going to use that
light energy to synthesize
to synthesize
sugar
very broadly speaking obviously this is
a very very high level overview
but light energy isn't the only input
here we're also going to need some water
and as we go into future videos we'll
see what that water is used for it's
actually a source of electrons
to do this to to go to make use of that
light energy frankly and we're also
going to need
we're also going to need some carbon
dioxide really as a source of carbons as
because there's a lot of carbon in those
sugars we're essentially going to fix
the carbon we're going to take it from
this carbon dioxide gas and we're going
to incorporate it into organic molecules
and eventually into
the sugar and sugar isn't the only
output another
byproduct of this process is molecular
oxygen once you strip the
you strip a couple of electrons from the
water and the hydrogen ions are stripped
away from it as well all you're left
with is molecular is is oxygen and you
do that twice then you have o2 and you
have molecular oxygen and this is a
byproduct of photosynthesis but you can
imagine this is very important to life
on earth as we know it in particular for
us we would have trouble breathing if
this was not a byproduct of
photosynthesis now what i'm going to do
now is break this out into two stages
and these two stages
we can call the light dependent
reactions
light
dependent
dependent reactions
and then the second stage i will call
the calvin cycle
calvin calvin
cycle
and as the name implies the light
dependent reactions are dependent on
light so what's happening here is we're
going to take light energy
light energy plus we're going to take
the water as a source
of electrons and we're going to use
these two things
we're going to use these two things to
produce
to produce let me write this in another
color to produce
atp
from adp so we're going to produce atp
which is a store of energy and we're
also going to reduce
nadp plus into n
a d
p
h which has energy as a as a strong
reducing agent so this is what is
happening broadly speaking in the light
reactions and then in the calvin cycle
what we're going to do is we're going to
take these products of the light
dependent reactions
so we're going to take our atp
and our n a
d
p h and we can use their energy in
conjunction with some carbon dioxide
with some carbon dioxide
in order to produce
in order to produce sugar
in order
to
produce sugar
and let me see have i got everything
here oh of course i'm i'm missing one of
the byproducts of the light dependent
reactions a very important one i'm
missing the molecular the molecular
oxygen
so once again this is what makes up
photosynthesis but you can break it up
into these two segments light dependent
reaction is using the energy from
photons in light along with electrons
from the water to produce to store
energy as atp and adp nadph and it has
oxygen molecular oxygen as a byproduct
in order for to get one molecular oxygen
you're going to have to need two of
these water molecules
and then as we go into the calvin cycle
we can take these the atp and the nadph
along with some carbon dioxide and we
can use that to actually store our
energy as
actual sugar
and as we'll do in future videos we'll
go into more depth and what exactly
happens in these light dependent
reactions and what exactly happens in
the calvin cycle